hey youtubers is charlie so big
surprises this morning lots of stuff
being said about Marvel's Netflix series
Netflix is just having like a big press
tour right now so they're talking about
all their stuff Marvel is just like the
big point of interest Netflix's chief
content officer just said that they'd be
dropping a new Netflix Marvel series
every six months now whenever I said
something about this on Twitter a lot of
you guys asked wait does that mean that
Jessica Jones is coming in October
because that's six months after
daredevil season one no that's not the
case this year Jessica Jones isn't
supposed to drop till December probably
like right around Star Wars when you dig
into like what the netflix people
actually said it's a little more vague
they just said at least a new series
every six months and they didn't really
clarify what was going to happen when we
get to season two of a lot of series
because by the time we get to defenders
will be on like daredevil season three's
so does that mean though they'll be like
for Marvel Netflix series airing in the
same year the best answer I can give you
is probably it's happening with Marvel's
movies right now they're getting to the
point where they have so many characters
and so many movies that they want to
make that they have to release three
films a year instead of just two I think
next year they're still only supposed to
be two movies but but then after that in
2017 they'll get to three movies a year
so it's the same thing happening with
the Marvel Netflix series I don't think
that that's actually like super huge
news just because they have like four
major characters that they're basing
individual series around and then
they're doing the team up of other
defenders so of course they're gonna
have to do like two or more series each
year to get them all out they don't want
it to be like 10 years before we see
that defenders miniseries so by all
accounts like if you're in college right
now jessica jones will air when you go
on winter break daredevil season 2 will
premiere before Captain America Civil
War I don't know how close little drop I
think a lot of it depends on how soon
they finish it like they're really down
to the wire Jessica Jones just had their
wrap party just like last week so
they're trying to finish everything as
fast as possible that's the biggest
reason they don't say upfront the exact
day that they're going to premiere it on
just because they're not sure when post
production is going to be done with all
the episodes you have to remember that
that like the Netflix series are a
little bit different from traditional TV
on a traditional TV series like arrow in
the flash for instance or agents of
shield they can start airing episodes
after they finish the first couple and
they just continue production it takes
them you know about six
weeks or so to make an episode that
includes shooting it with the actors and
post-production like all the way through
special effects so when you have like 22
episodes of season like you can start
the season before you finish all 22 but
on netflix they have to finish all 13
episodes before they can start airing
them because they drop malt once the
news that got me really excited though
is that they are starting to develop a
Punisher spinoff series I mean it's like
early early stages so I don't think
anyone's writing any scripts or anything
like that yet but he's such a big
character that is it's a no-brainer to
think that if things go well with
daredevil season 2 and everyone likes
Jon Bernthal then they will totally do
with Punisher spin-off series of course
we want more Punisher if it's possible
it's really not so much a money
situation just because netflix has such
deep pockets so it's like you know they
have the money to make it it's just they
want to make sure they have the right
team behind it they want to have the
right actors in the right story so that
all takes a long time to figure out so
don't be surprised after daredevil
season 2 comes out like around like this
time next year if you hear talk of a
Punisher series The Punisher that we're
going to be seeing in daredevil season 2
is a little bit different from the
punisher you've seen in the movies that
Punisher is like a fully formed Punisher
you know post family like he's already
taken on the persona he's super hardcore
he's wearing the comic book costume the
netflix version will be proto punisher
we'll probably see a condensed version
of the origin story you know just like
daredevil season 1 was all about him
building up to that costume at the end
building up to the persona same thing
can happen with the Punisher I know
everyone wants to know like how much
these series are going to cross over
they did say once each character gets
its series like you know daredevil of
jessica jones Luke Cage iron fist then
they would cross over into the other
series so don't be surprised if you see
like a little bit of daredevil and
jessica jones he i don't think he's
gonna have a big role but he'll at least
be mentioned because they're kinda in
the same area of New York but the
characters will totally bump into each
other before defenders like defenders
won't be the very first time that they
meet here's my big question for you guys
you know if they choose like a comic
book story to do for this Punisher TV
series eventually what do you want to
see them adapt right now daredevil
season 2 is going to be somewhat of
daredevil versus Punisher which was like
a big comic book storyline I mean
they'll be best buds probably by the end
of it but they're going to be fighting
each other when they first meet
is really interesting dichotomy between
Daredevil and kingpin in season one for
you know kingpins like you're just like
me and dared I was like I'm nothing like
you you're crazy daredevil wants to save
his City but there's like there's
certain lines that he's not willing to
cross that is not the case for the
Punisher the Punisher is so crazy that
during civil war in the comics captain
america's team wanted nothing to do with
them he's the one that brought them like
spider-man's broken body he was like he
needs help and he offered them his
assistance and they were like thanks for
good Punisher you go off and do your own
thing by yourself you're a little too
crazy for us this is why Walking Dead
fans went so crazy when Jon Bernthal was
named as the Punisher because Shane is
the Punisher like he was almost playing
The Punisher before he became the
Punisher so if you want a good litmus
test for like what what he might feel
like is the Punisher just watch like the
crazier Shane episodes of walking dead
in season 1 and season two speaking of
which there is like some Walking Dead
coming up I was originally going to make
a Walking Dead video of the day but all
this this netflix Marvel stuff happened
so there should be walking dead next and
then I'm going to be doing some marvel
movie stuff there's also some flash and
arrow stuff happening in like two weeks
too they're going to do their press tour
so we might find out some more about
what's going on with those shows be sure
to subscribe to get everything if you
guys haven't seen it they actually they
change the alert system they updated the
mobile app so if you click on this like
this little bell on my channel on your
mobile phone it'll send you alerts
whenever I upload videos so it's like
it's way simpler like your phone should
see an alert it's not perfect it doesn't
work a hundred percent right now but
it's better than the old system but you
can also follow me on on Facebook and
Twitter I usually you know post funny
stuff and video updates and stuff
they're there links for that in the
description below so while you guys wait
for all the new stuff to come this week
I've already done a couple daredevil
season two videos explaining Punisher
some of my favorite Punisher stories as
well as Jessica Jones what's going on
with that series you can click here to
learn all about that and you can click
here for my aunt man Easter eggs if you
haven't seen those yet be sure go see
the movie if you haven't seen it yet
it's a lot of fun thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you